je dirais que dans ce gîte et philippe
pasqua écrivent ans auteur du livre mon
songe d'état aux éditions max milo
bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions on vient de le voir edouard
philippe réélu confortablement wavre est
chargé par emmanuel macron de
réorganiser la majorité est-ce que c'est
se cacher pour mieux réapparaître en
2022 il part avec avant les
répercussions économiques de la crise
sanitaire au moment où sa popularité
semble au plus haut déjà ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que moi quand je vois le
bilan de d'edouard philippe j'ai
vraiment l'impression son bilan
ressemble à ce qu'on pourrait appeler
l'épaisseur d'une feuille de papier à
cigarette pour reprendre l'expression
d'un même premier ministre
qu'est ce qu'il a fait en fin de compte
edouard fille pas grand chose casser le
code du travail
bah craquer les gilet jaune faire une
disposition de loi pour la vitesse à 80
kilomètres heure qui était complètement
abscons et malvenue qu'est ce qu'il a
fait dans son bilan de trois ans rien et
par rapport à cette proposition d'
emmanuel macron de lui demander de
réorganiser cette majorité ça veut dire
quoi
ah bah ça c'est ça c'est vachement
marrant sert ce mec est même pas même
pas adhérent du parti en marche ça veut
dire quoi c'est bien que le président
n'a pas trouvé dans ses propres rangs un
mec qui est capable d'organiser la
présidentielle de 2000 22 mai mais je
rigole je trouve ça vachement marrant
que le président lui-même nomme
quelqu'un d'extérieur pour s'occuper de
sa prochaine campagne présidentielle en
ça veut dire que vraiment en marche il
ya vraiment plus personne il ya le
remaniement qui devrait être imminent
ainsi richemont en croit les mots de
jean castex qui veut je cite aller au
plus vite avant lundi donc avant lundi
ça veut dire aujourd'hui à quoi est-ce
que vous vous attendez après avoir nommé
donc un premier ministre sarkozyste il
peut y avoir des personnalités issues de
la gauche
l'entourage de l'élu et le manoir
construit un remaniement d'ampleur
mais oui mais oui il va y avoir encore
quelques personnes qui vont se faire
entre guillemets je pèse mes mots a
acheté pour pouvoir donner une image de
communication commune
mais en fin de compte on a qu'est ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui on a un ministre du
déconfinement qui va nous présenter
gouvernement de la déconfiture ça va pas
péter très très loin encore ce
gouvernement mais vous allez voir il va
y avoir quelques quelques lièvres qu'on
va sortir du chapeau vous savez des
magiciens ils sortent de temps en temps
des lapins on a l'air tous étonnés mais
on sait tous qu'en fin de compte c'est
un truand d'âge au fond du chapeau jean
castex rencontre demain soir les
parlementaires est ce que ça veut dire
que le gouvernement sera constitué
écoutez il faut lui poser la question
moi je suis pas premier ministre et
sûrement pas dans ce gouvernement là
donc oui oui c'est en train de se
dépêcher vous savez ils n'arrêtent pas
de faire du madoff c'est la course en
avant aujourd'hui 1 ils font n'importe
quoi n'importe comment
donc ils sont prêt à prendre n'importe
qui pour vouloir redorer l'image du
président mais on amis qui comme premier
président là on a maintenant du marcel
pagnol ou moi avec ce type là on va
pouvoir rigoler de temps en temps parce
que l'autre ils étaient plutôt poster en
plus d'être efficace les les profils des
ministrables potentiels sont
certainement l'imaginent entre la main
de la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique
ce qui est d'ailleurs simple nantes
surtout quand on connaît les précédents
béraud sarnez delevoye coûte de
l'exemplarité un des membres du secteur
gouvernement alors alors à écouter
permettez-moi de rigoler doucement parce
que cette haute autorité de la
transparence ne fait pas son boulot à
chaque fois on découvre que c'est
déclarons soit pas payé leurs impôts
soit 5000 soit soit 5000 euros qu'ils ne
payent pas tous les mois donc c'est de
la rigolade
ces mecs là nous on ne vérifie pas ces
gens là on les vérifie ap a posteriori
et quand on vérifie a posteriori la
plupart du temps on maquille donc là la
transparence de la haute autorité
excusez moi si vous avez des preuves
pour dire on maquille j'ai des pieds pas
seulement des preuves s'est défait
comment ça se fait qu'on s'est aperçu
que de la veille
six mois après payer que oublié de payer
5000 euros par mois comment ça se fait
qu'on s'est aperçu
six mois après que madame belloubet
n'avait pas fait les choses comme il
fallait
comment ça se fait qu'on s'est aperçu
six mois après que 50% du gouvernement
avait des problèmes avec le fisc ou avec
ou avec la justice expliquez-moi est
justement là avec ses précédents faits
est-ce que juste
- jean castex est justement cette
institution font en sorte de ne plus
avoir de casseroles entre guillemets
mais déjà cher monsieur si c'est
vraiment ces gens là voulaient vraiment
faire les choses ça fait cinq ans que je
réclame un casier judiciaire vierge b2
pour être élu pourquoi ils votent pas
cette loi là expliquez moi ça serait
déjà vachement simple pourquoi la
plupart de ces gens là on s'aperçoit
qu'ils ont tous des partis pris comme un
ancien secrétaire général avec des
cousins de la famille qui bosse dans des
grandes sociétés qu'on favorise au
niveau du gouvernement expliquez moi eh
bien c'est pas moi de l'expliquer mais
vous avez répondu à nos questions
philippe pascot merci d'être intervenu
sur la route étrange rappelle que vous
êtes écrivain auteur du livre mensonge
d'état aux aînés avait avec avec un s
mensonge